the Joe Rogan experience to shoot a duck
with a band on it everybody knows it's
cool as [ __ ] like I know that everybody
wants to shoot a band most people listen
this don't know that it's cool [ __ ] if
you get a band dark why is that well
it's a little bit social science because
long ago like we used to not understand
this can a little bit tricky to explain
we used to not understand how migrations
worked because everyone he only knew
what they saw okay and there wasn't
someone who was sort of like coalescing
all of this information people would
know very well like you know wherever
you live along the Mississippi River
okay and you might know very well that
like in November shitloads docks that
you haven't seen they have been here all
year are coming from the north and going
to the south and you knew that very well
you knew that ducks moved you knew that
they move through here but you didn't
put all of the you had no way to put all
the pieces together over time we wanted
to understand like animal migrations
better and one of the early this is way
pre collars like GPS collars and pit
tags and [ __ ]
we started this banding system where you
could go and catch a duck and it's we're
in its nesting area there's like times a
year when it's really easy to catch
ducks one you can catch them on their
young and you can catch them when they
molt so people would go out and put a
band on a dock and you'd go you could go
up and in the Arctic or the Upper
Midwest anywhere and throw a band on a
baby duck and that band would have a
phone number on it and you were
encouraged to when you got a banded duck
it was like they made it be that it was
a good thing and you were encouraged to
call that 1-800 number whatever the hell
they were before 100 numbers and given
the the band the band number and then we
started to really with like great detail
map out flyways how ducks migrated like
that the ducks in on the Arctic slope in
Alaska tend to follow along this path
and they
to end up here at this date there down
and you know whatever they're down in
Texas all of a sudden or they're down in
Southern California they're there
they're hanging out in rice fields
around Sacramento or whatever the hell
it is we started to put together this
whole detailed picture and it was one of
the great achievements and wildlife
biology was what we learned from the
duck banding system so I think that over
time it became like I said it was sort
of like social engineering where people
were taught to think it was cool and you
would wear and a band you would if you
had a lanyard where you keep your duck
calls on this still goes on if you got a
lanyard you have your duck calls on any
banded bird you get you put that band on
your lanyard I even met these
knuckleheads from North Dakota who have
a lot of bands on their lanyards from
banded Birds they've shot Andy but I do
that's a lot of bands he goes yeah not
one of them is reported mm-hmm they
think that it that it remains more peer
to do it I don't know that's the dumbest
[ __ ] ever it's the dumbest [ __ ] I wish
you guys did like why would anybody want
to contribute to oh I don't know you'd
have to have like a calling component to
your show and we would call one of these
dudes and have explained in greater
detail I remember thinking like that's
the most that that's the most [ __ ] up
thing I've ever heard but yeah I'm
thinking want to talk to that guy it was
like he's like yeah they're all
unreported anyways I don't know if it's
like an anti-science but you love to
argue did you talk to that guy about
this you know it was long ago I could
take where I was standing I was in my
brother's kitchen the Miles City Montana
beneath this crazy chandelier he bought
online and I remember everything about
it I don't remember when I if I
challenged him on the sense of being
proud of having not contributed to our
scientific understanding of waterfowl
migrations and why maybe it looked like
a sort of anti-government sentiment like
some black helicopter stuff okay
regardless yeah it's a malicious [ __ ]
it's cool to have bands and I have like
in my sort of I have like a box where I
put important stuff to me but imagine if
you had a box of deer collars dude
there's no way if ice I wouldn't put
into your car that's what I'm getting as
like those are cool but collars are not
and we had a friend there's a there's a
friend of mine who's a she's a does a
lot of carnivore
search and other research projects named
Carmen van Bianchi which is a cool name
but she says that you know I'm someone
that collars animals and I even think
that she's like when you get one with a
collar on it she said it was quote we
talked about this here today she's like
someone has already got the best of them
that they become tainted when they've
been held by someone else and that's a
little bit how I view it we're like a
wild animal you want to imagine it being
like the wildest wild animal and once it
has a collar it's like someone it's it's
all sloppy seconds man
[Applause]